voilà le numérique est donc exhorté hier
l'onu à agir contre la russie au regard
de ce qu'il qualifie de crimes de guerre
alors que l'envahisseur renforce ses
positions pour prendre le contrôle de
l'ensemble du dombass armelle charrier
bonjour l'est c'est le nouveau front sur
lequel tout va probablement bientôt
bientôt se jouer c'est en tout cas
annoncé comme tel un avis partagé aussi
par le secrétaire général de l'otan
viennent seuls tendeng il estime que les
russes vont tenter de réaliser un pont
terrestre avec la crimée déjà annexé
c'était en 2014 oui c'est le nouveau
front et en même temps ça toujours été
le feront que vous voulez des russes en
fait c'était s'emparer du du donbass
pour avoir cette profondeur stratégique
avec l'ukraine à voir ces quelques
kilomètres et surtout ensuite récupéré
la mer d'azov alors là techniquement ce
qui me font c'est qu'ils ont arrêté
d'avoir une occupation qui soit vraiment
par le nord parce que ça leur permet de
redéployer les troupes des troupes qui
arrive par l'est la russie et des
troupes qui vont monter en fait par la
ville de marioupol une fois qu'elle se
relâcher et puis des troupes qui vont
arriver j'allais dire dans le dos on
fait des ukrainiens l'idée c'est de
prendre ces combattants ukrainien a
guéri mais il de les prendre en tenaille
en fait alors 150 mille hommes ainsi les
russes ramène ensuite des gens face à 30
minutes craignent un qui est à peu près
on est dans une position qui est tout à
fait efficiente là pour la peine et a
même si on est comme vous le rappelez
les ukrainiens connaissent parfaitement
le territoire puisque il ya une
combattent depuis 2014 dans le doubs la
zone du dombass en fait ce sont des
régions qui sont bombardés c'était le
cas encore la nuit dernière il ya eu ce
matin 7 cet ordre d'évacuation lancé par
gouverneur de la région de loin de ce
que on appelle les civils à fuir cette
offensive imminente